hello out there time for another movie
retrospective we're doing a good one
today we always do good ones oh yeah
good in some way or another this is the
2002 British werewolf flick Dog Soldiers
yeah I've never seen this [ __ ] love
yeah I've never seen this when Jenny
showed it to me it's kind of like the
the British predator it is it does have
a very similar kind of setup yeah a
bunch of British Air Assault guys that
are on training mission they got their
black adapters on their little with a
little Enfield and feel Bullpups that
they're carrying and they go out where
is it Scotland I think it's actually
supposed to be the Scottish Highlands
okay so Scott
that's not where they filmed it but
that's what they're doing some field
training and they get attacked by
werewolves it's gonna like it's kind of
like like my predator reminds me a
predator because everybody at elite in
this movie is at least competent yeah
you don't have any you know screaming
teenagers or incompetent people it's all
pretty competent soldiers and one thing
leads to another and they find out that
the SAS was out there I guess it's SAS
yes it and that SAS got wiped out they
picked up some of the SAS as weapons and
picked up the mission to try to fight
these damned werewolves it's pretty cool
well that's cool guns that's cool
equipment very similar to this it's kind
of it kind of the British their
equipment always kind of reminded me of
American equipment this this movie I'm
looking at it the equipment if they're
wearing really kind of reminds me of
what I was wearing in the army back of
the 90s you know the weapons are pretty
cool you know
and finding cool mp5s and FAL based
rifles FAL rifles and shotguns and
pretty cool pretty cool yeah they
basically kind of have a big standoff
it's almost kind of like almost kind of
like the Alamo where they're inside a
house trying to fend off an attack from
a bunch of these werewolves yeah this is
a totally badass werewolf Lee and I mean
there's not like I guess werewolf movies
are not as like
well represented in the horror genre say
like vampire movies or zombie movies of
which there are forty bajillion well you
could say that there's that one what's
the one with the zombies first there's
you vampires versus werewolves there was
that whole series oh yeah underworld
underworld was that underworld probably
the best and I guess Twilight had where
was it but that's not really yeah what's
that darling the first howling was okay
I was gonna say that like of the kind of
few where because it seems like
werewolves kind of get the short end of
the stick a little bit of the few
werewolf movies that there are in the
horror genre there are very few that are
actually any good um you know American
Werewolf in London
obviously I've called the first howling
is very good Ginger Snaps is very good
which came out the same year as this or
the year before but had kind of a
different take on it but other than that
there's really not that many good ones
but this one is a really really good one
that the werewolves themselves kind of
reminded me of the howling I mean there
there's no CFE these are actual costumes
but they're really well done the faces
are animatronic on them and the guys are
really [ __ ] tall because they have
you know I guess fake legs or fake feet
like stare they're like stilts like
goats but they they're articulated so
they can kind of jump and run around I
had some acrobats yeah dancers they got
all days for the werewolf plan the
werewolves and they're you know it's
pretty cool pretty cool they look good
yeah I mean 30g for a movie as
low-budget as this is I believe it was
made for about two million dollars and
this was actually as most people might
know this was Neil Marshalls first
full-length feature now he obviously
went on to much greater things he did
the descent which is also a fantastic
[ __ ] movie he also did one called
doomsday which I haven't seen
I believe he's gone on now to direct
some Game of Thrones episodes so he did
like you know he he did really good with
his career later on but like I said this
was his first full-length feature before
this he had done like a short film
called combat which has a couple of the
same actors in it that are in this but
he had been working on this script since
the mid 90s I think like 1996 the first
version of it and he basically he had
whole idea where he's like I want like a
whole bunch of like elite soldiers like
fighting werewolves and but it took so
long to get made because you know what
I'm funding and all this other kind of
stuff and um but what he did with this
now because here's the thing this did
not get a theatrical release in the
United States which is criminal yeah but
you know it got it got a theatrical run
in the US and in some other countries in
Europe and it actually did pretty well
like I said it only cost two million
dollars to make so it made more than
twice its budget back yeah you can't
tell that this is two million it looks
like more but it does but it just goes
to show and we talked about this a lot
if you know what you're doing and you're
competent you get a good crew and you
have a good story and good actors and
stuff like that you don't need a lot of
money to make a good movie well I think
that I think this might have been about
this that's probably about what it costs
to make predator actually yeah and
predator although this was many years
later many years letter but predator
really carved out a fantastic franchise
for itself just on the back of a roof of
a cheap but very strong movie yeah a lot
of what made predator great was the dam
monster and the actors of course and it
was it was just a whole tale all
together the score and everything and
this movie kind of reminds me of that
yeah because I mean the the werewolves
the the the way they look it looks as
good as that first predator yeah you
know and then there's many of them in
this was probably what six seven them
yeah it's gonna hurt so but it's like oh
yeah it's like a whole family of
werewolves they're like several
werewolves yeah and the score is good
the way it shots good it kind of was
some of its kind of grainy which so was
predator yeah is the kind of film that
was shot on yeah it was shot on 16
millimeter which is cheaper at the time
which is why you know even if it I mean
it did get a blu-ray release from Shout
Factory in 2015 I believe but it's never
going to look rah like crisp and HD and
everything like that but some people
might [ __ ] about that but I actually I
think that that contributes yeah the way
that cuz the film looks like kind of
older than 2002 because it was shot on
an older film stock it's kind of a
throwback kind of feel to it kind of
like I said and the way predator was and
maybe like alien to like aliens yeah dad
it was good you know it has the same
vibe yeah bunch of soldiers fighting
monsters it works good and I mean like I
said you have really like all the
elements to make a really good movie I
mean it's slightly longer than a horror
movie I think it's a usual [ __ ] maid
spent an hour and 45 minutes but it
doesn't feel like it there's no really
no fat on it but the thing that is
really one of the best things about it
other than the werewolves which look
amazing like I said there are no there
is no CGI in this at all they're all
dancers and they all have full-body
prosthetics and these huge like really
awesome looking werewolf heads that have
like servos and other like electronics
in there and they just like the way they
move is like really cool yeah and also
like the way they shoot them is really
cool like sometimes they'll just show
them like outside of the house and
they're just in silhouette and they're
all Shaggy and everything like that and
they'll show them like running through
the woods really quickly but I think
this is kind of a thing where it's very
good because less is more with the
monsters like yeah you see them and
stuff but they're kind of in shadow or
they're running or you just see like
parts of their bodies and stuff and
every now and then you see them like
like walking around and they look really
awesome but I think like what a lot of
people really like about this movie and
what like the heart of this movie is is
the guys that's what I was gonna say
like all the actors in US are really
really good I mean a lot of them had
done like British TV and some of them
went on to like much greater things
later on but you immediately are
invested in these characters they're all
likable they're all they seem like a
real like army unit they seem like dudes
that know each other really well they're
always like bantering and like talking
[ __ ] to one another and I'm like they
all have their own little personality
quirks so they're like easily
identifiable it's it's kind of easy to
fool civilians you know you know I mean
a lot of movies fool civilians into
thinking that that's the way the
military is but you know these are
supposed to be British Air Assault you
know air assault infantry is what they
are and that's what I was in the Army
aren't first Airborne Division was in
the first and the 506 and the first in
the three to seven so these guys are
representing the same cotta soldiers me
and my buddies were yeah and I'm telling
you it was authentic yeah as our thing
that I did feel like I was looking
British soldiers it's very natural it's
very organic like all of these actors
have such a good rapport with one
another and they're just like talking
[ __ ] yeah very much similar to that in
real life the only thing I'd have to say
that I thought was [ __ ] is the scene
where the guys remember and going
through his survival escape & evasion
programme with the SAS they asked him to
kill that dog yes but that was like
shorthand for showing that captain Ryan
was about yeah that's that was for shot
that was true that was [ __ ] they
don't do that yeah they went they
wouldn't do that in the British Army or
in the American army but I understand
why they did it yeah you know it's for
the movie but I thought maybe they could
have done something a little bit
different like something was a little
bit more realistic that he didn't want
to do yeah I thought it might made the
British SAS look kind of cruel yeah
that's not the way they are right but
like I said they were foreshadowing
because that guy was a villain yeah so
they wanted to kind of show like a kind
of shorthand without like early on in
the movie and they're showing that coop
was a good guy
because he wouldn't is that's the way I
saw it on yeah I'm an ex soldiers and
soldiers get offended when they try to
make soldiers look kind of bad
yeah but of all armies so you don't mean
even though bad [ __ ] does happen that
particularly wouldn't have happened yeah
yeah but I mean like I said because
captain Ryan is a bad guy and really it
was just him because like the rest of
his squad the SAS squad you know later
on when the you know the the main guys
in the movie like they come across
what's left of his unit and they've all
been eaten except for him and he's
wounded so I'm assuming that all the
other guys you know they they were just
normal regular dudes yeah and who didn't
know like what was going on really but
they all got attacked and killed by the
werewolves so so in that way I didn't
mind it like I said it is a little like
unbelievable but werewolves closest
closest thing I've ever heard of that is
James Earl Jones he should be an Army
Ranger yeah and in old Ranger school
he's telling the stories that you had to
carry a snake with you for a long time
during the course all right and and of
course you had to eat the snake but that
snake yeah maybe that's cold-blooded
animal and you eat snakes as a matter of
course
anyway for survival you know in jungle
jungle anyway it's free meat still
though it tastes good you know me it's
like if I had to carry a snake with me
the whole time I would get attached to
the snake and I wouldn't want to hurt it
yeah well they care you're carrying a
snake against for food but they don't
tell you this they don't tell you tell
you this food so you like certain a
minute I guess oh yeah but slithery
that's according to James Earl Jones not
like something do back in the sixties in
Rangers believe that does kind of sound
like there's yeah like I said shooting a
dog is a little but like I said they
were trying to show that he was like a
bad guy because you find out later on
and this is something that I guess like
in the original versions of the scripts
like this there was kind of this subplot
where because you know once the army
unit like starts gettin attacked by the
werewolves they get they get attacked
and then they get picked up by this
woman named Megan who turns out as a
zoologist and she takes them to like
this you know this really remote like
farm house like out in the [ __ ] its
but like I said it's supposed to be the
scottish highlands but it was actually
filmed in luxembourg actually on the on
the land of the duke of luxembourg who
let them film on their land because they
got like tax breaks and stuff so she
takes them there and it's kind of a
thing where when you know they bring
captain ryan there because he's wounded
he was the only SAS guy that was left
all the other ones got eaten by
werewolves cuz there's like gore all
over the forest and everything and
there's kind of a couple moments in
there where Meghan and captain Ryan like
look at each other like they know each
other there's some [ __ ] going on and
then it turns out like as the story goes
on that captain Ryan and his SAS unit
they were supposed to go out there and
capture one of the werewolves alive
because you know the government Loren to
like you look into using them as a
weapon or something like that so and I
think the implication to is that the
army unit that's like at the you know at
the center of the movie I think they
were supposed to be like the bait like
to draw the werewolves out you know what
I mean so which they didn't know like
they didn't tell them like what this
mission was because I think there's like
some conversation between them at the
beginning though like the you know the
one guy was pissed that he was missing
the
you know England versus Germany soccer
match which is a big deal if you're like
from over there that's like you know I
mean England versus Germany that's like
a huge you know match up but so he was
pissed about that and he's like you know
and they would didn't even tell us like
what this mission was were just like
supposed to be out here and doing this
that the other who were supposed to be
like some kind of capture the flag side
type of thing but it turned out that
they had been sent out there on purpose
to draw the werewolves out so that the
SAS team could capture one you know
alive so you find that out later on and
like I said there's some [ __ ] going on
with like Megan - so you're kind of like
led to believe that Megan and Captain
Ryan have spoken before and that like
either she was part of the plan or she
knew about the plan because she says
she's been studying the werewolves and
she lives out there and then later on
like near the end of the movie you find
out spoiler alert that she is a werewolf
- although it's not real clear when she
becomes a werewolf I don't know if she's
been a werewolf the whole time because
she didn't wolf out with the rest of the
family because by the way that's who
lives in this farmhouse is the family
that are werewolves so I don't know
because there is one point in the movie
where she like cuts her hand and they
kind of make this big deal about like
showing it and everything and I always
kind of wonder if she like got werewolf
because what what that was supposed to
be was there was supposed to be a sequel
to this and they kept talking about it
like for ages and ages it was supposed
to be called fresh meat I think yeah and
what Neil Marshall said was like oh that
we you know where we showed her getting
cut you know the sequel was gonna have
something to do with like the DNA like
the world with DNA or like that and that
was supposed to be like foreshadowing
that but so some people have said that
maybe Megan wasn't a werewolf the whole
time that that's when she got the
werewolf cooties because she didn't like
I said all the other werewolves were
they were already werewolves and they
were running around outside and like how
could she keep from turning into one at
the same time as they did cuz she didn't
walk out until almost the end of the
movie yeah so I kind of feel like she
got turned later on so and I think the
same thing happened with Ryan I mean he
got attacked by the werewolves so he was
gonna wolf out - but he didn't wolf out
until the end of the movie also had good
special effects really good pretty gory
you know
it had done play was good yeah like
everything that and like you said I
think it's cool because for the same
reason that predator was cool is because
these guys were you know trained for
this for these types not werewolves
obviously but for this type of situation
so they weren't just like a bunch of
clueless doofus yeah losers or anything
yeah nobody did anything stupid nobody
did anything you know they did someone
that had been trained and that wouldn't
do yeah some of the guys were getting
into it they're like getting it yeah I
mean seriously one of the best
characters I think coop is the best
character he's the most sympathetic but
um a lot of people their favorite
character is spoon because he is just
like he does not give a [ __ ] and you
know what I mean it's just like he'll he
goes out and like acts as like a
distraction for other people like waving
a [ __ ] flare in their faces and it's
like one of the werewolves breaks in and
he's like he doesn't have a weapon
anymore he's just like throwing like
Forks and [ __ ] at them even though it's
not doing anything then he puts his
[ __ ] dukes I'm sponging the [ __ ] you
know the credit [ __ ] it's if you like
predator you'd like the movie if you'd
like to alien to you'd like the movie if
you'd like to howling you'd like the
move it's kind of like to me it's like a
combination of them all yeah and it's
like it's really fast-paced and there's
like you can tell that somebody that was
really into horror movies like made this
because there's a lot of omage is like
very subtle I'm just like CID like Evil
Dead The Matrix you know and predator a
little bit so he kind of like made sly
little winking references to other
movies in this as well all like I said
you can tell he's a big horror fan all
the military equipment they're wearing
was spot-on for that time and for that
terrain you know I mean there's none of
that crazy body armor that they have
today or the combat shirts or none of
that [ __ ] it was like still [ __ ] do you
really live in
yes just like LCEs or LBV which is just
nowadays you probably call a battle belt
you know some of these guys calm down a
bit and just uh we've got gore-tex tops
and bottoms and you know in that British
pattern and you know they all started
off with the correct rifle they all had
that damn British bullpup but then they
got their hands on SAS weapons and they
were all accurate you know they had a
mp5 with flashlights you know the
late on it and I don't read dots and
kind of modified FAL type rifles and
shotguns and it was good man it's pretty
cool I liked it it really does look like
they made an effort to make everything
like as accurate as possible so nobody'd
be like they wouldn't happen and all
this yeah it was pretty accurate but
yeah I was gonna say another thing to
like about spoons character and about
him just like he knows he's gonna get
killed like so he just wants to mix it
up with the werewolves and [ __ ] like
that and like before the werewolf eats
him he it's like this [ __ ] great line
where he says I hope I give you the
shits he [ __ ] werewolf eats him and
it's funny because I think in the
original cut of the film they actually
showed him getting like torn apart by
the werewolf be good but people liked
his character so much that they didn't
want to see that so they only showed I
mean they show the other soldiers like
finding like he was all like all these
guts and everything all over but like
you couldn't really tell it was him
anymore that was just guts all over the
floor but uh yeah I thought that was
kind of funny but yeah like I said the
Goron this is really good I was actually
watching a review of this earlier and
this never occurred to me but I think
this might actually be accurate because
there's but like if people are gonna
nitpick about the movie they're like oh
what what is this family and how is
Megan related to them was she a werewolf
the whole time what are they why today
because when they first find the
farmhouse there's like dinner cooking
you know what I mean there's like a stew
on the stove and it's going and there's
like dishes out and like some guys were
like well why did they like make dinner
if they knew they were gonna wolf out
because you know presumably they've been
werewolves for a long time you know it's
a full moon and [ __ ] cuz you keep track
I mean obviously yeah but one thing like
when the soldiers start eating the stew
and he says he wasn't sure what kind of
stew it was but it might be pork and I
was thinking well maybe Megan or the
werewolves made that stew and it's human
meat yeah because later on when they're
down in the cellar or the barn or
whatever they find like bodies which I
which I think are the bodies from the
campers from the very first thing they
were inferring that they were eating one
I thought they were eating like people
me yeah you know what I mean it didn't
really occur to me until I was watching
this other review I'm like oh yeah well
that would make total sense wouldn't it
because they were making a stew out of
because they were keeping the bodies for
some reasons they're probably just
chopping off some know
notice and liked about the movie was the
rucksacks alright yeah even in predator
all right which is still to this day one
of my favorite movies they're not
they're not curing any rocks now some
people might say well it's a tropical
environment they're only about there for
two days they're not carrying a rucksack
well these guys are you know supposed to
be out there for weeks you know yeah and
we used to carry big-ass ruck sacks
heavy you know sixty pound ruck sacks
maybe seventy but if you are RTO you can
have a rucksack maybe eighty 90 pounds
specific gonna bet for a long time carry
your own bodyweight people call you
don't carry your own bodyweight yeah
yeah especially winter you'd carry your
own bodyweight and equipment well these
guys are carrying big ass rocks these
are like man rocks huge rucksack
yeah and normally they don't show those
in the movies kind of like well they
don't look that good on film I think
that's probably why I think that yeah
they don't look mobile they don't look
at with that but the reality is is that
you're carrying your own body well
because you would have way to survive
out there right and then you're carrying
all the weapons yeah and you might be
carrying any tank mines landmines or
rockets or mortars for [ __ ] for mortar
tubes you'll even have so you're
carrying other people's ammo too you
know and so I like that so that added to
the authenticity yeah like I said these
see if you're young like a real Army
squad like they had all the [ __ ] like
the war between them and stuff yeah and
I mean they start they got those damn
yellow blank adapter is on the end of
them yeah the barrel which they look
like [ __ ] on camera but that's how you
but that's what as literally when you in
train you carrying that blank adapter so
everybody knows you got blanks and you
can fire blanks yeah you know on the m16
it's just a red square that goes on
there and you screw it on you know the
British one was that long yellow blank
adapter yeah and seeing that I just I
liked it because I like man they would
never do that in an American movie yeah
because they think it would look bad
yeah because if it look bad didn't like
it didn't look like a real gun it
admitted make them take that blank
adapter off and said no but reality be
had that mic adapter on there yeah then
maybe miles gear which is that damn
laser tag gear which looks like [ __ ]
yeah but they didn't have that but you
know maybe Britain didn't use that we
didn't take it all the time either
feel just about what what kind of field
exercise it was and actually yeah they
in the situation here they probably
wouldn't take it the only thing that
wasn't really quite that actors is just
one helicopter maybe a squad a six seven
guys yeah I never went anywhere in that
small of numbers usually they move a
whole company at least you know yeah but
it was just a movie and like I said
because there was like the underlying
motive that they didn't know about that
they were just supposed to be out there
for bait for the world maybe they just
but because they were talking about how
weird this mission was they didn't know
well yeah so yeah so they did like
actually sort of make reference to that
even though it wasn't like blowing up in
your face it wasn't like super over
explained or anything you just had to
like listen to their dialogue yeah they
landed it I think that might have been
on oh-58 which is an observation
helicopter you know I mean we would have
showed up in a uh-1 or a uh-60 you know
a Blackhawk er uh or a Huey yeah but
they came in and I think looked like I
know aged 58 or something like that
maybe a European equipped equivalent I
don't really I remember it as being a no
858 but you know that's just the way it
is it's a movie yeah yeah and another
thing too that I want to mention this is
not I'm not gonna call this a horror
comedy by name stretch of the
imagination but there is like a lot of
humor like threaded throughout it like
you know just most of the humor comes
from the interactions of the characters
with one another and like some of the
[ __ ] that happens like when the where
will start attacking like there's like a
really funny scene where the werewolves
like big claw like comes in through the
mail slot or whatever and they kind of
starts whaling on it with a hammer cuz
that's like all he's got and [ __ ] like
that
so you know that there's a lot of that
too even though it's not like a comedy
per se but there is like a lot of comedy
threaded throughout it which is actually
really really well done and like really
organically done an infantry squads got
a lot of comedy running through it
anyway yeah in real life yeah dudes
[ __ ] with each other constantly and
talking yeah and that's exactly where
the humor comes from and I think that's
really good because it doesn't seem like
it's shoehorned in it doesn't seem like
oh here's some humor to relieve the
tension or anything like that it just
seems like a soldier's do that
automatically it seems yeah it seems
like a very realistic situation that's
how people would react because this is
kind of a crazy like unbelievable
situation in reality it's a bunch of
dudes
oh they're all been living together in
close quarters for years a lot of times
some of those guys I was with him for
four [ __ ] years
they're almost kind of like your family
and all they do is just [ __ ] with each
other and you know it's basically like a
big tough man competition who's the
[ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] puss basically it's
like it which is exactly like pretty
much what it is like you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what I mean but it's like
it's just great it's just so like one of
the one of the soldiers like barfs on
the head the other one it's like one you
know one of the guys gets is like guts
hanging out but he lives but they're
like trying to fix him and everything
and like the dog like takes his
intestines is like ah get on it's tough
but it's not done like oh look how wacky
or zany it's just it's just I mean the
British type of humour is a very
particular kind of humour which I've
always liked it so it's kind of dry and
deadpan and stuff so I think that uses
that very well I've heard a couple
people complain that the accents in this
are so thick that they can't understand
what people are saying very thick I
didn't have a problem but like I said I
night there I spent a lot of time in the
UK like in the you know late 90s early
2000 good idea direct translate I didn't
have I knew what they were talking about
yeah situationally yeah it's it you can
like infer um I mean but I have seen
some people were like well I had to turn
on the the closed caption if they
couldn't tell what they're saying I
didn't have that problem but a lot of
people do because I mean they do have
like very thick like regional accents
and stuff but yeah it's seriously if you
liked the descent which I don't know if
I'd i guess the descents a better movie
but honestly it's hard to compare
because they're kind of different but
and if you haven't seen this one and
it's it's such a shame to me that this
didn't get a theatrical release in the
u.s. it's just unbelievable to me it's
like it went straight to the sci-fi
channel and then and then it came out on
DVD and then blu-ray and stuff there's a
lot of corruption involved in the
theater system here you know what I mean
it never got a distributor it's like
even though it won a ton of prizes it
like various horror and fantasy
festivals like in in Belgium and
somewhere in Europe but they just never
going to distribute
so like a social hierarchy and of money
hierarchy of whose movies gonna play in
a theater alongside this one you know my
buddy he put this movie out we want this
one to win at this day that's we want
this one to make all the money that's
you know I mean they're playing those
games and the theaters yeah but I mean I
feel like this one it's sad it didn't
get a release but at least now
especially since the dissent was such a
huge success that people actually went
back and like sought this movie out
because I feel like it's kind of like a
cult classic and pretty much every
review I've seen of it it's like you
know this is easily easily one of the
best werewolf movies ever made oh yeah I
mean easily that's it not even an
argument I'd put this up there with
[Music]
howling and American Werewolf in London
yeah better than American Werewolf in
London I would say even though all those
are good movies that I just mentioned
yeah I probably put this one above the
other two actually just it's yeah it's
more of like an action yeah more like
actually they're different Connor movies
even wulfings even they're not woken up
howlings a different kind of movie even
though I think that's a good I thought
that was a good werewolf movie yeah it's
a movie of its time yeah you know but it
did have it has some [ __ ] bad-ass
practical effects for the time they
still kind of stand up there it doesn't
look real but it puts on a good show
yeah that's it yeah that's what I mean
it's like you can tell that that's a
person right but but still that's cool
I mean well a werewolf is a person just
a person that your dad put a CG werewolf
there you would just look like oh yeah
whatever well that would look like crap
like every other CGI monster looks like
yeah pretty much yeah you know it's not
there right you know kind of like with
that new predator the big CG super
predator yeah it looked okay but I knew
that that wasn't there yeah I would
rather have like really have like a
goddess ooh yeah a guy in a suit even if
you know it's a guy in a suit well if
it's CGI you know it's CGI the predator
is a guy to suit but Danny that's
looking [ __ ] looks badass yeah then the
aliens from aliens do yeah and they all
of those look better than CGI I think so
especially CGI monster they're worse
CGI aliens like an alien vs. predator
you know it looked decent yeah look
decent look good it only to me it only
looks good if it doesn't move around too
much this one is when it moves it's like
too fast or too weightless or something
a VP I think it was either 1 or 2 wander
in the temple I think it was the first
one they moved you didn't see him for
very long and that's that hell yeah that
definitely helped yeah
but in this one really I mean like I
said the way they shot it a lot of it
was in darkness or in shadow they did
show them like full-length a couple
times like coming down the hall or like
standing up over a bedroom because
they're really tall they're like 8 feet
tall 7 8 9 feet tall something like that
because they're on the stilts they
showed them like in the there's a
documentary about the making of and
they're these kind of like they look
kind of like um you know like those desk
lamps it looks kind of like that so they
had these big things that they were
standing on but I think I mean I think
they look fantastic and I think it's one
of the best-looking
werewolves like that they've ever put on
film now another thing that people this
is another nitpicky thing that people
[ __ ] about 90 to even like this didn't
even occur to me until I was watching
some other [ __ ] but some people said
that this might be and correct me if I'm
wrong this might be the only werewolf
movie that doesn't have a transformation
scene yeah and that's it's funny because
that never I never even noticed there
probably expensive in kind TV that's
what I'm saying and like some people
were like oh I wish there's been a
transformation scene instead of just I
mean they showed Megan like her eyes
went yellow and they she had you know
and Brian like he didn't really
transform his eyes just went yellow any
kind of werewolf in london has a pretty
good one I remember well remember the
howling is having good ones yeah yeah
yeah that was I I did Rob butene do that
I kind of think maybe the guy that did
the thing I liked I liked the howling so
so much that I actually they watch -
howling - but I regretted it it's funny
I watched it when I was a kid yeah I
liked it and it didn't bother my watch
it again and I'm like what the fly got
about ten minutes in I'm like it was bad
it wasn't even like so cheesy that it
was entertaining it was just it was like
a totally different movie it's like it
wasn't even related to the howling one I
kind of feel like that might happen a
lot because I think what happens
especially with these kind of like you
know lower budget properties I think
sometimes they'll be like scripts like
kicking around Hollywood that didn't
have that didn't originally have
anything to do with that movie but then
somebody gets a hold of it and goes you
know we could tweak this and make it you
know we'll just put a couple scenes and
that sort of link it back to that and
then it'll be a sequel kind of like
scanners I remembered loving all the
scanners movies but only the good only
the first one was good hold on I liked
this movie this is terrible watch
anything I guess pretty much yeah well
you know you see you just don't have all
your critical effect I knew this star
crash was bad even though even though
Carroll of a Rose hot ass is running
around still you know but I liked it but
I knew it was bad I knew I wasn't
dealing with stark Star Wars right you
know member battle beyond the stars
there was another piece of [ __ ] yeah
yeah but you know the whole thing about
this seriously I got it on did I get it
on a DVD or blu-ray I can't remember I
think it was the blu-ray actually yes
okay I got it for like three bucks or
something like that and FYE at the mall
TBD
yeah they had that big bin with like all
the cheap-ass DVDs and I was like so
excited because I was like oh Dog
Soldiers and I haven't seen it and I
knew he would he hadn't seen it in 19
and I knew he would really dig it you
had not seen The Descent yet either no
I've seen it twice have you yeah I'm
down there I've seen it twice but there
was a long time in between each time
that I saw and it really wasn't paying
close it down I thought you bought it
you bought it
I bought it to one I wanted to step
Reese tuddy it but it won't play on my
xbox it'll only play on this this yeah
okay I thought you said you haven't seen
it no I've seen it twice but I didn't
really watch it that closely the first
time I saw it was on an airplane and it
stressed me the [ __ ] out cuz I already
hate flying so then that then I saw that
movie again and I'm like oh great like
everybody's I walk but this one actually
interested me more than the descent yeah
because it's more more your kind of
thing it's like it yeah it's relatable
to you it's military guys and yeah if I
can punch and werewolves and stuff yeah
and I remembered like not
you know the the subterranean people in
descent I thought that was pretty
[ __ ] cool but I don't remember them
actually showing much of them they
didn't really seem to have much
personality was kind of like a zombie
they were a little bit they were yeah
they were just lazy like they were
creatures there was animals they were
were they people I thought they were P
they were like mutated I thought they
were people that had yeah evolved for K
they did yeah yeah but you know over
however long have any eyes or anything
and I think yeah or they did but they
were like really small or something I
have to like remember but that yeah they
were all white kind of reminded me of
just as rage zombies that's what they
reminded me of so I I didn't really find
him to be that fascinating maybe had had
they been a monster that could speak and
it had it like its own culture maybe I
would have liked it better although what
I liked the most about the descent
wasn't even the monsters it was like the
all the backstabbing between the
characters and all the claustrophobia to
me that was scarier than the month yeah
that's a central theme of that movie
yeah was all those girls they were
mostly girls from whatever they were all
women they were all girls yeah they were
all they were all cavers I have to look
at it yeah but yeah um so yeah if you
liked the descent then you really need
to check this one out if you haven't
seen it easily like I said one of the
best werewolf movies ever made and
certainly one that I have you know
watched repeatedly and I enjoy just as
much every single time you know so and
like I said if you need to put on the
closed captioning I won't tell anybody
but yeah so check it out if it's your
kind of thing and that will do it for
our latest movie retrospective we will
see you next time bye